When the weather gets cold we can go inside, we can put on a sweater, animals can
migrate
–they can hibernate, but plants they're
really stuck
they can't go anywhere so they've
developed all these really amazing
adaptations
to deal with things that went to eat
them –to deal with the cold and so
a vegetable like a carrot that's growing
in the ground – in order to
defend itself against the cold it's
developed all these amazing
physiological responses including
increasing the sugar content
and so increasing the sugar content
helps defend against ice crystal
formation which
can do all kinds of terrible things
the cells like dehydrate and crush them
–and rupture them
along with many other responses. This increase in sugar content helps defend the
carrot against frost and cold
and the great benefit that is that when
we harvest those carrots in colder
weather
they close much sweeter